in early 2017 Tomb Raider fans
everywhere got their first look at
Swedish actress Alicia vikander as the
series iconic hero Lara Croft in the
upcoming film franchise reboot but while
Tomb Raider is vikander latest
big-budget action role the star has been
all over the place in the last decade
moving from Swedish indie darling to
a-list celebrity here's a look at why
the new Larry Croft looks so familiar
pure what are the first films to land
Alyssia vikander some international
recognition was 2009 Swedish drama pure
directed by Lisa Lang Seth the film
stands out as a real masterpiece of
Swedish cinema landing vikander best
actress and leading role honors at the
Swedish version of the Academy Awards
and launching her on the path to
superstardom a royal affair the candor
followed up her breakthrough performance
in pure with the supporting role
opposite mas Mickelson in the 2012
historical drama a royal affair the
critically acclaimed film earned Best
Foreign Language Film nominations at
both the Oscars and Golden Globes which
is ironic considering Danish was
actually a foreign language for vikander
as well
she told the independent I had to call
my friend's mother who was half Danish
she actually recorded all the lines in
Danish on her iPhone and sent them to me
so I was able to practice on my own Anna
Karenina
McAndrews debut in english-language
cinema came in joyrides 2012 film
adaptation of leo tolstoy famous novel
and a Karenina filming the Russian
classic was quite an adventure itself
the candor told the Guardian it was 40
below we didn't have hot water for five
days and slept in a cabin on a bench on
our call sheets it actually said beware
of wolves they are known to attack lone
humans we saw a wolf one time and a bear
but there was some very tough Russian
security guards that came along it was
one of the most fantastic adventures
I've ever had in my life but I don't
need to do it twice the fifth estate
vikander's english-language acting
career started gathering steam in 2013
when she landed a supporting role in
Bill Condon's WikiLeaks thriller the
fifth estate opposite Benedict
Cumberbatch she told GQ I knew a lot
about WikiLeaks already one of the most
famous documentaries about it came out
and Sweden before the war logs were
released and Julian Assange was still
considered a very brave man Hotel 2013
saw Alyssia vikander star in the Swedish
drama film Hotel
when she plays Erica a mother struggling
with postnatal depression who finds
comfort in hotel rooms the candor found
herself attracted to the script because
she enjoys playing uncomfortable roles
and because she had already worked with
the film's director at Lisa Lange Seth
on pure she told her finery 29 I was
really drawn to the script many women go
through postnatal depression if they
have a family but it's still a very
taboo subject I've never really seen it
portrayed on screen I mean I didn't even
really know how it would work just by
reading the script I was quite amazed at
how Lisa was able to bring it all to the
screen ex machina 2014 would prove to be
a very big year for Alyssia vikander due
in no small part to her attention
getting turn in Alex Garland's ex
machina in the sci-fi psychological
thriller vikander played Ava a beautiful
and dangerous robot powered by
artificial intelligence a role that
landed her with a slew of Award
nominations the Canon was happy for the
change of pace telling indieWIRE I just
loved those intimate psychological
sci-fi films then this script came along
and it's one of the best scripts I've
read normally you come in and work on a
script and Alex was very open to us to
change it but it was just a very
finished product it's a page-turner
testament of you the Cantor's stunning
performance in ex machina was followed
by her portrayal of writer Vera Brattain
and James Kent's film adaptation of a
World War 1 memoir testament of youth in
an interview with Collider vikander
discussed the difficulties of playing a
real-life character you want to
especially give justice to her family
and friends who actually still live and
who remember her who knew her that was
probably the most nerve-wracking thing
to meet them in person and do that but
they were so nice and they were really
there to support son-of-a-gun
Alyssia vikander's third film in 2014
was julius Avery's australian crime
thrillers son of a gun the candor told
indieWIRE she was hooked from the first
page when I read the script it had such
a pace and then it turns into a heist
thriller so as very intrigued to see how
this director who I thought was a very
art house director would do something
like that seventh son sergei bodrov
fantasy adventure film seventh son was
the fourth high-profile release
featuring Alyssia vikander to hit
theaters in 2014 but it was actually one
of her very first gigs having been
filmed several years earlier the candor
told NGO pride calm this is how Studios
work with releasing movies it was a big
experience for me because it was the
first American film that I got The Man
From UNCLE in 2015
vikander made the jump to blockbusters
with Guy Ritchie's reimagining of the
hit 60 television series The Man From
UNCLE having appeared primarily in Indy
or lower budget films The Man From UNCLE
was a new experience for vikander she
told vulture I mean they closed down the
Spanish Steps in Rome I was like are you
kidding I couldn't believe it but that's
what you're able to do when you have
those budgets and it was a huge gift to
be able to experience that I could walk
out on the street and feel like I'd time
travel with 200 extras and all the shop
frames change to look like the 60s the
Danish girl in 2015 vikander took on
what would become her most famous role
to date as Danish painter Gerda Wagoner
in Tom Hooper's film adaptation of David
Eber softs transgender novel the Danish
girl vikander won the Academy Award for
Best Supporting Actress but while she
was happy with the win she didn't think
it was really a big deal she told Vogue
I think it's all just buzz and if people
recognize the film and talk about the
film then maybe that will bring
audiences to see our film it's an
important story to tell so that's all we
want
Bernt rounding out 2015 vikander
appeared in the John Wells cooking drama
burnt in which she appears in a very
brief role as Bradley Cooper's
ex-girlfriend the film was a commercial
and critical disappointment so maybe
next time the producers will do the
smart thing and give the candor more
screen time Jason Bourne 2016 saw
Alyssia vikander continue her rise to
mainstream stardom with the portrayal of
CIA cyber ops division head Heather Lee
in the fifth installment of the Bourne
series Jason Bourne it was a dream come
true from a candor who has long been a
fan of the franchise
she told the independent I was a
teenager when I saw the first film even
if it is a popcorn franchise movie it's
very intriguing because it has elements
of political and social issues that you
recognize and yet is still very
entertaining the light between oceans
after playing a department head at the
CIA the candor returned a period fair
starring the 2016 romantic drama the
light between oceans the candor's
on-screen romance with co-star Michael
Fassbender immediately led the popular
speculation that they were having an
off-screen romance although neither
actor would confirm the rumors since
filming the light between oceans though
the pair's private romance has been a
hot topic for tabloids turning the stars
in the
NU'EST it couple tulip fever a 2017
vikander returned to period drama and
tulip fever the movie was actually
filmed back in 2014 though and as you
might expect the long delay was due to
the fact the film apparently just isn't
very good
still with a full docket of high-profile
releases on the horizon including that
Tomb Raider reboot we've only seen the
start of what promises to be a long and
fascinating film career thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]